.
DIALEHTS THAT YOU MISSE
YOUR SEORAYLES AT BECOME A
OTH
S ITSELF,
, ITSELF ORL P
OVERNIGHT.ST
T, YOU THERE IS NEVERING TO B UE
CONTINUE, MOSTF ALTHEY
ANON TG TH SYOU, HASHE JOY OF M
CA MY ON-AIR COLLEUEEARLIER
BUT I WTOUBLE BACK AND SAWONGOR
YOU MAKE WORK NOT WORK.
W,U ATE,E
YOU ARE STENING ONHE RADIO
CHINON THEADG  START
BEYONDFOIS THEIDE
ARMY FIRST THO
NABEFORE I GO  SLEEP.
ROF, YOU AND IHAD A GUARDIAN ON
EVERMOWE ARE SO N
AGE OF SOCIADIA, SO ILWE NOTHEMD
ON
RR HEREBOOK.S
BGEND
LIVERY, HLN IS NO
CE S'S MORNING SHOW,
MEANS THAEAVE YOU IN
R HAND O
CORPORATE COUSIN TO OUR
OURNALIST.
U , VE HEAHASES
AUSE YOU FEEL
G GEDOU MOURNULY APPRIA
SOMEWAS.
NS THIING ARRECIATAR RUN.
YOU WILL ALWAYS BE MY MORNIN
SUNSHINE.
K YOU.